- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the homeroom livestream.
It's been a little while
since we last saw each other,
so, good to see you again,
we have an exciting conversation
today with David Siegel
who's a co-chair, co-founder of Two Sigma,
which we'll learn more about,
and also the founder
and head of the Siegel family endowment.
So we're gonna talk a bit about that
and maybe most importantly,
at least from my lens,
a long time supporter
of all of the incredible
of all of the work,
incredible supporter of all of the work
that we've been trying
to do over the years
and someone who I also consider
a close friend and advisor.
So I'm very excited about talking
that conversation before we jump into it,
I will give my standard announcements.
First of all, a reminder that we are not,
for-profit primarily funded
with philanthropic donations.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to Khanacademy.org/donate.
Also wanna give a shout out
to several organizations that stepped up.
Some of them longtime supporters,
some of them relatively new,
but when they saw that,
especially during the pandemic,
our costs had gone up
and our usage had gone up
a special thanks to Bank of America,
AT&T, Google.org, NOVARTIS, Fastly,
and General Motors.
And of course, this is not an
exhaustive list of the many,
many folks who have been
supporting us over the years
and also through the pandemic.
And then last but not least,
there's a version of this live stream
that you can get in podcast form,
wherever you would get your podcasts
"Homeroom With Sal The Podcast."
So with that, very excited
to introduce David Siegel.
David good to see you.
- Good afternoon, happy to be here.
- And there's many things
that I wanna talk to you,
David, about.
Some of what we've
talked informally about,
but I think people are
gonna be really interested,
but I do wanna encourage
folks who are listening in,
especially on social media,
put, start putting your
questions in the message boards
on YouTube and Facebook.
Questions about, investing,
questions about the economy,
questions about
philanthropy and education.
These are all of the things
that we will talk about right now.
But David, maybe we'll
start with what, you know,
your "your day job",
which is co-running Two Sigma.
Can you explain to
folks what Two Sigma is?
- Sure. We're an investment
management company.
We like to say that we're
involved with financial sciences.
A lot of people say they're
a financial services company.
We've kind of coined the
expression financial sciences
because we try as best as we can
to apply the scientific method, data, AI,
and analytical and quantitative methods
to the investment process.
And a lot of people think of investing
as something that is done, you know,
seat of the pants that, you know,
you use your intuition gut instincts.
You know, we've always
believed that, you know,
applying the science to a problem
always gives you a better answer.
It really doesn't matter
what field that you're in.
You know,
the application of the scientific method
has really advanced,
virtually every domain
that we know of, you know,
when medicine was done,
you know, in the dark ages,
you know, seat of the pants,
you know, the outcomes,
weren't all that good.
When the scientific method was adopted
in the field of medicine,
advanced into something,
you know, really disciplined.
Then we began to have the breakthroughs
that we have in modern medicine today.
And, you know,
I firmly believe that
investing is the same story.
And so Two Sigma, we really,
you know, apply algorithms,
data, various other let's call
them scientific approaches
to try to drive a better
investment outcome.
- And it's really
fascinating because you know,
you have a very deep academic
background and as you know,
many academics will tell you
that markets are efficient.
You can't beat the market, you know,
just modern portfolio theory,
just by a big basket of
things, diversify and just,
you know, let it ride so to speak.
But clearly you and John Overdeck
who founded Two Sigma with
believe differently and other
people believe differently.
(inaudible)
There is a science to this
that there actually can be ways to
outperform the market generally.
What gave you that conviction?
And I am curious on your
entrepreneurial journey,
how did you fall into this?
Or how did you make the decision to,
start an investment firm like Two Sigma?
- Well, you know,
the statement about the
markets being efficient is,
you know, it, you know,
at a high level it's true.
You know, the markets are pretty efficient
and, you know, particularly these days
when the markets, you know,
benefit from, you know,
ready access to lots of information
and the markets, you know,
there are many different
ways to access the markets.
You know, hundreds of years ago,
the markets were not
particularly efficient
because, you know, people had
advantages on information.
People didn't even, you know,
very few people had access to the markets.
So, you know, the world
is moving in a direction
that is making the markets more efficient,
but they're not perfectly efficient.
So I think, you know,
when people do make the statements
that the markets are efficient,
I think really what they're saying
is they're pretty efficient.
So what that means is that
it's actually a little bit more difficult
than you might think
to actually outperform the markets.
But that doesn't mean it's impossible to,
so the question that you
have is if you have a belief
that you're going to be
able to outperform an index,
like the S and P 500, you know,
what would your,
some people would call
it your advantage be?
You know, what, why do
you think, you know,
what do you have access to,
that would give you
the ability to do that?
And in one, you know, our answer would be
well, we're, gonna be
very scientific about it.
We're going to use a lot of data.
And, you know, we're
gonna look at the markets,
primarily using a lot
of computer algorithms
in a way that it's hard for,
you know, sort of the old fashioned,
very gut instinct based approach
to compete with.
So that would,
that's the reason that we believe
that despite the fact that the
markets are pretty efficient,
that we can do better.
- And when y'all were starting the firm,
you know, you do,
you did have,
(inaudible)
you did have experience
working at previous
firms like this.
Was it like, you know,
I think we can do better.
I think we can do better
than the state of the art
that's out there.
And I, I'm curious to, how did you
and John have some initial algorithms
that you had back tested and, you know,
for those who don't know backtesting is,
hey, we have a theory,
we have an algorithm,
let's take this algorithm on historic data
and see how it would have performed.
And you're like, yeah,
I think we got something interesting here.
How did you, how did it start?
I'm always curious about that
phase of an organization.
- No. It wasn't like
that. It was more just a,
you know, it's like any
entrepreneurial exercise.
I think that people just have
a belief and a conviction.
And so you just, you know,
we started with a blank sheet of paper,
but just, you know, literally a belief
that this is the future and, you know,
no different than I think
virtually all tech startups,
most of the successful companies
that you have today
that have emerged that of Silicon valley
and elsewhere, you know,
they've often just started with a belief
that this is how, you
know, we can do better.
And, you know, so really just a belief.
- Yeah. And that belief
has been validated.
I am curious, I mean, as someone who has,
who studies markets
with a scientific lens,
as you mentioned, you know, what,
there's been a lot of talk about
a case shape recovery about
some people are doing just fine.
Other people are doing less fine,
even before the pandemic,
people have been talking about
how automation and technology
they're going to benefit some folks,
but they could hurt other other folks.
I know this is an area that
you've thought deeply about,
and obviously you're in it
and in certain ways.
Where do you think we're heading
from an economic point of view?
What do you think the
impacts of the pandemic are?
What do you think is going
on in markets right now?
And what do you think we
need to be hopeful for,
or watch out for a little bit longer term?
- Well, you know,
these are really gonna be
just my personal views,
not of the company.
You know, I just wanna be clear.
This, isn't the kind of
thing that the company
that these are not exactly
the kind of investment
approaches the firm takes.
So speaking really just
entirely personally,
and you know, this is,
I don't think actually
a new trend in America.
It really does appear that
our economy has been moving in a direction
where certain people are doing, you know,
better and better,
and other people are falling behind.
And, you know,
I think that this accelerated
during the pandemic
for a number of reasons,
I can really quickly go into them.
I mean, we could talk about
this for hours and hours,
but I think a lot of the bifurcation
of economic outcomes are being caused by
fundamental changes in our economy
that are driven by technology in,
you know, the rapid transformation
of the global economy, you know,
because of technological innovation,
the internet, you know,
you're all familiar with,
you know, obviously Google
and Uber and, you know,
there are dozens of
companies that, you know,
are virtually brand new
and, you know, Amazon,
these firms have changed
the way all aspects
of our economy function.
And when you have a big
economic dislocation occurring,
driven by technological change,
that is going to, you know,
restack the deck,
the people that benefit will be different
than the people that benefited before.
Other people who thought
that they had stability
in their work will find that
they no longer have stability,
the kind of skills that you
need to get ahead, change.
You know,
everyone knows today that technical skills
are more valuable than
they were ever before.
People that have mastered
certain kinds of technologies,
you know AI is one of them have, you know,
had unlimited opportunity
in the new economy.
People with, you know,
certain other kinds of skill sets
where automation has taken over,
have been falling behind.
And this trend accelerated
during the pandemic
in part, because people were investing,
firms were investing very
heavily in more automation,
looking at more ways to reduce dependence
on traditional human based approaches
for doing things.
So, you know,
this is one of the many
factors that are driving,
you know what I would call, an alarming
change in our economy,
which, you know, we have to,
as a society we need to address.
- And do you think this is
something different about
what we're going through now versus
previous periods of technological change?
Obviously, people talk about
the industrial revolution.
Yes, people who are
driving a horse carriages,
or I guess even the horses themselves,
I guess horses probably
did lose a lot of work
during the
(inaudible)
the automation with cars,
but a lot of people point to that and say,
well, you know, yes, a lot
of there was a lot of flux,
a lot of change and things,
but at the same time,
overall jobs were created.
There was a broad based middle-class
that came out of the
industrial revolution.
So this revolution might
not be any different.
It could be change, but
overall it will be better.
But then you hear on the other side,
people say, well, I don't know,
artificial intelligence, automation,
they're kind of getting
deeper into what human beings
are oftentimes capable of.
Where do you fall on that debate?
- Well, again, a very
complicated question,
try to give over probably
over simple simplified answer,
but I do not believe
that there will be a lack of jobs.
There is plenty of work
that only humans can do.
And as we automate certain kinds of work
we're freeing up people
to do other kinds of work,
and, you know, we have an aging population
there's gonna be a need for
more people, just as one example,
more people to take care of the elderly.
There is a crumbling infrastructure
all around America.
We need more people to rebuild this.
You know, the robots are not gonna be
handling this kind of work.
People have now changed
their shopping habits.
We need more people to
deliver all the packages.
You know, it's unlikely
that we're gonna have,
you know, despite all the hype,
I don't think drones are
gonna be really changing
how we get deliveries in,
you know, anytime soon.
So the amount of work for people to do,
it's not going away.
But the problem is that,
you know, we have to
have an adjustment here
and we have to decide if,
we're going to be able
to pay middle-class wages
for the new kind of work.
And, you know,
it is possible that, you know,
a lot of the new work,
people are only gonna want to
pay relatively low wages for,
and maybe these workers
won't have the ability to,
in any way organized to get higher wages.
So you might end up with a relatively
large amount of work
at wages that are not really suitable
for middle-class living.
Now, it, you know,
the previous industrial revolution,
which is, has been well studied,
of course the outcome was
a vibrant thriving middle class.
But, you know, you have to remember
that the transition from say the beginning
of the industrial revolution
to the thriving middle-class,
you know, also brought with it, you know,
World War one, World War two,
there was a lot of trouble,
there was a depression in there.
So it wasn't really a smooth transition,
but eventually you got to a spot
that was actually pretty good.
The goal here is to make sure that
we don't have a bumpy ride.
Certainly we don't want to
repeat anything like that
when we go to this new economic phase
that is being heavily driven
by a new wave of technology.
- Yeah.
No, it's a really good point.
And, you know, oftentimes the economics
and the history of things
like wars and often comes get disjointed,
but they are connected
in probably more ways
than even the history books,
try to draw connections.
I mean, what do you think, you know,
just stay on this question,
and I'm getting a lot of questions from,
I'm assuming young people on, you know,
what advice would you
have for them, you know,
given the world that we're
going into and all that.
So I'll, it'll be a double question.
What advice do you have
for them as individuals,
but also what advice do you,
are you thinking about for society?
I know you've thought,
and you've written about some of this,
you know, what's the role of government,
the not-for-profit sector,
the for-profit sector.
How do you think about this?
- Well, you know, government,
again, Sal heavy question,
give me an easy question.
The, you know,
the role of government is
obviously incredibly important
in society.
You know, I think people in many,
in my own personal view
is people essentially take
government for granted because
in many cases, what
the government is doing
is providing infrastructure.
They're providing things
that are kind of behind the scenes,
and then all the excitement
that the infrastructure
that government provides then
leads to the vibrant economy
and the good outcomes.
So the, you know,
the private sector is
built upon the foundation
that the government has created.
And, you know, when I'm
talking about infrastructure,
I'm using a very broad definition.
You know, the government, you know,
in many cases is involved
with physical infrastructure,
like roads and bridges and tunnels.
And the government may very
well be involved with more
modern infrastructure as well.
You know, either directly
or indirectly for policy decisions.
The government is obviously
involved with education.
The government is involved
with the rule of law,
creating an environment
where businesses can thrive.
The you know, there is
no such thing by the way,
as a capitalism, without
a government intervention,
you know, the economy is...
All economies,
the US and every country in the world
they're, you know, they're
not just, you know,
the private sector without any rules,
the government creates rules of the road.
And so this infrastructure very broadly
is critical for a thriving,
not only the economy,
but just for people to live good lives.
And so I think that, you know,
government well-functioning government
is incredibly important.
- And what's your advice?
I mean,
there's a lot that we could talk for hours
just on the governance
piece or for profit.
And we'll talk about
philanthropy in a second,
but on the question of
individuals, you know,
for a lot of the young people
who are asking questions,
like, what should I do with my life people
(inaudible)
should I go into computer science?
How should I do it?
How should I navigate?
You know, what, what's
your message for folks,
how they be thinking about
their life, given what is,
what seems like likely to happen
the cross-currents of technology
and the economy and all of that?
- Well, you know, first and foremost,
I would start by telling
people that, you know,
they really need to pursue their passions.
There's no right answer.
Like if I were to say yeah,
the right thing to do is, you know,
become a, you know, AI specialist,
you know, sure that,
you know, there's gonna
be a lot of opportunity
for such people,
but that is not going to necessarily
be interesting to everyone.
So I think the key thing is that,
you know, in today's world, you know,
look it is, you know, it's
a relatively tough world.
You know, people aren't struggling
to find their way in our economy
because it's changing very quickly
and the skills that people
need are not obvious.
But I think, you know,
the thing that's most important
is, you know, to have the
passion for what you're doing.
And if it's something
that you really wanna do,
it's much more likely that you will,
you know, put the energy
into it, to succeed.
I, you know, look, the
obvious answer of course,
is that STEM skills are more important.
You know, you should really get
your basic math skills down.
You know, you should spend
time on the Khan Academy
to perfect, you know, the material
that wonderful organization
has put together.
But I would definitely vote for
you gotta be pursuing something
that you're, that brings you joy.
Your life will be better.
You know,
don't pursue something simply
because you read somewhere
that it's gonna be the
carer of the future.
And it's very hard to predict the future.
So you, you know,
you might end up getting
that totally wrong.
Another thing I would
mention is that, you know,
the world is changing very quickly
and what this means is that
you're gonna have to really become,
you know, a constant lifelong learner.
And so whatever you know
your interests are today,
whatever the skills that you developed
through your education today,
keep in mind that you're
going to have to continue
to invest to make sure that,
you know, you're ready
for the next curve ball
that our vibrant world
is gonna throw at you.
So this, again, points to
trying to go in a direction
where you have a passion
it's kind of hard to force
yourself to continue to improve
and gain new skills in something
that you don't like at all.
So passion, passion, passion.
- I couldn't agree with that more.
And it's funny cause you know,
I remember when I was a kid and I had,
I did have a passion
for math and for science
and for things like
that and for computers.
But I also had a passion
for art and drawing and,
you know, the messages
that I got, oftentimes as,
you know, first-generation
immigrant family,
like that's not gonna be practical Sal,
that's a nice hobby,
but you know, you fast forward
today and you see that,
wow, you know, fields like
design are actually highly after
and can be very pragmatic
and you can do very well in them.
And that even, you know,
my own journey, you
know, I used to be in a,
at least a tangential field to yours,
but we were a different
type of investment firm,
but we were in markets and things,
and I enjoyed that and
I had a passion for it,
but I had this even deeper
passion for education.
And that if you just create
a little bit of space for it,
you know, we're in a brave
new world where opportunity
that no one could have
predicted the job that I have
or, even the type of organization.
So I think that's really
good advice is that
the combination of having
really strong skills,
probably anything that you wanna do
at some form of reasonable scale
and impact will involve
some type of technology.
But then you couple
that with your passions
and you can be quite formidable.
What you know, moving on to the,
another big piece of your
life, which is philanthropy.
And as I mentioned,
I'm very biased because actually
both you and John have been
great supporters of Khan,
your families have been great
supporters of Khan Academy
over the years.
But what got you into philanthropy?
Arguably at a relatively young age,
a lot of people go through
their stage where they're kind of earning,
and then later in life,
they start going into philanthropy.
What got you into it?
Why did you prioritize it?
And how do you, what's your
framework of philanthropy?
Where do you think that you can
make the biggest difference?
- Well, you know, the journey
that I took into philanthropy
started a long time ago.
You know, doing things to help people has
always, you know, it, you
know, we all have to do that.
It, you know,
I think that everyone in
society has some obligation.
I mean, some people say
you should, you know,
if everyone gives back a little bit more
than they take the world would be,
you know, forever a better place.
And so if you think just logically,
you know,
how did you get to where you are?
How did I get to where I am?
I was, you know,
benefiting from essentially
all kinds of philanthropic things
over my lifetime.
Education in America, you know,
is largely supported with philanthropy.
I got a really good education.
Everywhere i look,
I'm the beneficiary of other people
who decided that they wanted
to give back to society.
And that made me recognize
at a relatively early age that,
you know, I wanna do the same thing.
And also, you know,
as you start to do philanthropic things,
it makes you actually want to do more.
You know, so I find
philanthropy to be, you know,
in a way addictive.
You know, you get your feet wet,
you get involved with an
organization, you help them.
You know, you give with your heart,
you give a little bit from your checkbook,
whatever you can do.
And then I think virtually
everyone concludes, wow,
that felt great.
And you know,
it's so easy to get
involved with philanthropy
because there are needs everywhere.
And so, you know,
I started in a small way
and my own journey was, well, you know,
how can I apply what I know?
You know,
what are the special things
that I might be able to do to help?
And, you know,
one of the area that
I ended up focusing on
and that my, the Siegel
family endowment focuses on
is essentially to help people,
in the journey through tech,
the technological change that
our society is going through,
how are we going to prepare
and help people navigate
an increasingly technical
and technologically driven society?
And these changes that
are occurring, you know,
as we talked about actually
earlier in this call Sal,
you know, are very, very challenging
for individuals, for
institutions, for governments.
This technological
transformation is something that,
you know, I think that, you know,
my foundation can help you know,
improve the outcomes a little bit.
And that's what we're really
committed to be focused on.
- And I'm gonna go, a ton of
questions as a question related
to that from Catherine
(inaudible)
from Facebook,
what are your suggestions
for teaching young children,
how to be responsible, philanthropists,
guidance for giving please.
And I'll expand her question.
What's your advice for
philanthropists in general?
Because, you know, philanthropy,
doesn't always have the same
type of objective function
that you can get in the investing world
of the for-profit world,
where you can say, oh, I
put this much money in,
and I got this much money back
and philanthropy, you're
putting some Dollars
and potentially time and
effort and energy in,
and there is a return and impact,
but how do you think
about that and how do you,
what advice you have for people
both children
or other philanthropists
like yourself to do it well?
- Well, I, you know,
first of all, I, you know,
particularly for younger folks,
you know, I would put, you know,
a little more of the emphasis on time
rather than Dollars
because you see, you know, just,
you know, making a donation
to an organization,
you know, it's wonderful.
You should do that.
You know, as Sal mentioned
the Khan Academy has a donate page,
and I think everyone now
should click over there,
but there's something even,
I think, more transformative,
if you actually put your time into it
and putting your time into it
will actually make you
more likely to wanna put
your Dollars into it.
And you know,
young kids generally have
more time than Dollars.
And so I think that there's an opportunity
to get the youth involved
with philanthropy,
by picking community service activities.
That by the way,
I think that there's a big argument that,
you know in America,
we would benefit by having far more
involvement of young kids
in community service.
I think that this would actually
in general make a more cohesive society.
So my recommendation would really be,
you know, to pick philanthropic
community service activities.
And I think as a great
introduction, you know,
you do it close to home
because then you can see the
impact of what you're doing.
It can be much more direct.
And then this will, I think,
convinced even young people
about how incredibly wonderful
philanthropy is released,
because you can just see that your time
and your efforts really
made something better.
- Yeah, couldn't agree more.
And I actually think
there's tons of people
who wanna provide them.
(inaudible)
I will put a plug for another related
notforprofitschoolhouse.world
where folks listening could,
they can tutor give their time,
but you're really are
giving resources there.
Your time has a lot of value that you can,
give to other people.
I couldn't agree with you more, David.
You know these conversations
are all these fun conversations
always go way faster than I expected.
So maybe I'll just finish with one
kind of big question.
You know, you clearly are already doing
many, many big things and have
already done many big things,
but when you look at your
next five years, 10 years,
20 years, what do you
hope to be the impact?
What do you want the world to
look like based on work that
you're doing, maybe in
collaboration with others?
- Well, funny enough,
just this morning,
I was meeting with some people
from my foundation talking
about that very question.
Maybe they mentioned that to you.
- No.We're just linked.
(inaudible)
- Some kind of, you know, quantum effect,
The, Sal, that's a really,
actually the hardest question yet.
I really don't know.
I think that I, you know,
the thing that, you know,
I'm learning over time is that,
you know, really you got to
live your, you know, your,
the amount of the most valuable thing
I've got left is my time.
And I have to be very
careful of what I focus on.
And I have to also be realistic about
what I can accomplish.
You know, I think that, you know,
over the coming decades,
but I would really like to be able to do
is to impact,
you know, a broad range of,
I would like to make our society.
And this is really why the mission
of the foundation really is
about the impact of technology on society.
I would like to make our society
be one that is more fair,
that is more inclusive,
that has better outcomes
for a broader set of people.
I think that, you know,
it, you know,
if we all look back maybe
20 or 30 years from now,
I think we'll all be incredibly happy.
If, you know, we,
can all say that, you know,
over the last couple of decades, you know,
America and the world
was able to deliver good outcomes
for, you know, a diverse set of people
that we were able to,
bring to the world, you know,
the kind of equity that in
the past hasn't existed.
So I'd like to be able
to make an impact there.
- No, those are inspiring words.
And I think words worth pursuing.
Well, David, thank you
so much for the time.
Thank you, you, your family.
I mean, for just being
long time supporters
of not just resources, but
your time, your advice,
as I mentioned,
I consider you a close advisor
on all things we're up to,
so thank you so much for being,
for joining us, but even
more important for being part
of our journey here at Khan Academy.
- Sal it was my pleasure.
Really happy to be here today.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
Well, thanks everyone for joining.
I gotta tell you, you know,
David is someone I could
speak to for hours.
And sometimes we have
about everything from
investing, to the economy,
to philanthropy, and we have
a lot of similar interests.
So anyway, thanks for
joining this conversation.
I really appreciated your questions.
I'm sorry, i couldn't get to all of them,
but I look forward to our
next "Homeroom with Sal."
So you then.
Onwards.
(chime)